well it looks like the Final Fantasy 7
remake isn't the only Square Enix
re-release on the horizon if you're a
fan of Zidane and his adventures across
Gaia I've got good news final fantasy
nine is coming to PC and smartphones the
RPG will hit Japanese market sometime in
2016 though we haven't heard anything
about pricing or a Western release at
this time in any case the new trailer
looks pretty good showing off shiny new
graphics for the 15 year old game the
rerelease will also include achievements
auto saving a high-speed mode and a host
of other new features Square Enix's
final fantasy 9 has sold over 5 million
copies since its debut it was also
released on PSP PS Vita and ps3 and 2010
and with this rerelease it'll join the
trilogy of final fantasy 13 games on PC
we're certainly no strangers to final
fantasy nine at gamespot so the more we
hear about the upcoming release the more
you will too in the meantime we can all
keep grinding away until we finally beat
Ozma